today could bring new shakeups at the
White House National Security Adviser HR
McMaster could be the next high-ranking
official to go an unprecedented number
of top aides some two dozen have already
left the Trump administration major
Garrett is at the White House where the
president told reporters he wants to
quote see different ideas major good
morning good morning as you mentioned
John the president yesterday in the Oval
Office said there will always be change
that sounded possibly more ominous than
he intended that pace of change could
accelerate rapidly and in the very near
future sources here and on Capitol Hill
tell us the current national security
adviser HR McMaster very likely to lose
his job possibly as early as today
McMaster a three-star Army General
replaced Michael Flynn president Trump's
first national security adviser back in
February Flynn was fired by the
president for misleading vice-president
pence now about all this Sara Sanders
the press secretary last night pushed
back saying on Twitter that she had
spoken to the president and McMaster
saying they have a good working
relationship and there are quote no
changes at the NSC meaning National
Security Council possibly even more
prominently than McMaster the chief of
staff John Kelly we are told by two
different sources could resign as early
as today Kelly was brought in to bring
order and discipline last summer from
his post as secretary of Department of
Homeland Security and he had some
already success on that front but his
relationship with the president has
become increasingly strained the leading
to contender rather to replace Kelly
Office of Management and Budget director
Mick Mulvaney I'm told by numerous
sources Mulvaney is under very serious
consideration to replace Kelly Gayle all
right be continued for sure thank you
very much major